la première réponse et une photo de
nikos
c'est juste une photo denis kozhukhin
poteau de nikos ou nico ce que tu veux
c'est juste une photo de nikos will où
on va voir oui la question c'est quoi
la réponse est trop tôt de nikos que
faut que faut-il avoir assisté la voir
dans son slip à mykonos pour ne pas
faire la course
[Rires]
qu'est ce que j'aimerais bien avoir
comme ça au dessus de mon lit à wigan
après sa mort la chaussée les bisons
écoute number one c'est grave non lic
aux saveurs on saura la vache à lait je
préfère qu'elle soit amoureuse elle à
l'extérieur des camps sahraouis
oui bah un petit caméo un peu brun un
peu petit bar vend petit et on va merci
ça me fait plaisir ça me fait plaisir
d'avoir le même style que mon wapper
merci ce qui a été vendu en salle des
ventes pour une grosse forte somme
d'argent non ça c'est pas passé sur
internet c'est pas un truc qui s'est
passé sur twitter qu est-ce qu alors
qu'est-ce qui a posté thomas sotto sur
twitter la carte ont qu'a posté thomas
sotto sur les réseaux sociaux thomas
sotto journalistes qu'on adore 1
hier c'était l'anniversaire de nikos
nikos qui fêté ses 51 ans et qui a reçu
beaucoup de messages sur twitter dont tu
as qui n'est pas passée inaperçue c'est
un tweet de thomas sotto qui a ses potes
avec nikos et qu'il affichait hier en
publiant une photo mais moi je trouve
beau gosse à françois il est très beau
là et c'était la carte orange de nikos
regarder il est très bon à mon avis je
pense qu'il a et voilà c'est nikos l'a
bien pris il ya eu un petit échange
entre les deux c'était l'époque où il y
avait plus de gâteaux que deux bougies
voilà nikos aliagas merci cher monsieur
pour cette photo qui me rappelle que
j'ai été jeune
évidemment le retour de bâton sera si je
pars à la chasse aux photos de votre
jeunesse
voilà et thomas sotto fais gaffe à
l'élagage et du dos tu le sais et pour
se venger nikos a publié une photo du
permis de conduire de thomas sotto
regarder mais thomas sotto il a toujours
la même tête
voilà thomas surtout c'est une rebelle
alors justement on voulait avoir aussi
des photos des animateurs qui ont bien
changé à regarder on commence par un
facile je vous montre et qui sait vous
allez essayer de trouver qui sert gars
facile mais exceptionnelle la tt et nous
très content de chez vous et on viole la
meuf elle a reconnu jean luc reichmann
avec rihanna tu vois bien que il a pas
il a pas mal non non il a été ressenti
l'acceptant a été relooké la 7 ans
francis cabrel qui il est plus beau
battant et un scénario peu moins tard il
faisait fait remarquer et avant jean luc
hees érectile
il le raconte aussi je le dis aux
téléspectateurs avant il faisait
énormément maquilleuse qui avait sa
tâche de naissance et à au bout d'un
moment il a dit eh ben voilà il faut
qu'on m'accepte comme ça c'est vrai que
je trouve que il a pas une bonne
initiative sciences humaines et ça
dérange pas du tout et il est très beau
comme ça après son chauffeur de salle
chez béghin say that ans était chauffeur
de salle de nagui à la base c'est lui
qui faisait toutes les voix ont aussi
oublié à la brosse à dents sera d'or on
a les attentions
regardez sauver vous reconnaître cette
personne c'est une animatrice regarder
chez vous c'est valérie c'est valérie
non non non elle est très belle
franchement je la trouve magnifique
l'animal garder ce bon visage enduit
regarder ce beau visage quoi elle encore
animatrice aujourd'hui maintenant
maintenant elles vendent également des
devoirs des fleurs à rungis
ah tiens qui nous les a ramenés elle est
certes elle seule tu vas voir tf1 sur
tf1 pas pour qui l'événement draine
quétier non non pas sont inscrits y
aller chez vous s'est trouvé ce que dans
le public on la trouvait l'animatrice
laurence ferrari laurence ferrari non
non non anne sophie lapix non mènera sur
france 2 non non non non non c'est une
animatrice de tf1 regardez comme elle
est jolie
franchement regardez ce visage
magnifique elle a gardé le même visage a
vraiment jolie oui sublet non c'est pas
su blé non allez ça oui c'est qui
laurence boccolini bravo laurence
boccolini et oui c'est laurence
boccolini regarder
même souri le même sourire et elle est
magnifique elle est magnifique c'est
laurence boccolini
alors là regardez ce n'est pas un
inspecteur des impôts les
reconnaissez-vous cet animateur regarder
ses victimes et non mais c'est bien sûr
c'est laurent ok mais là il a 75 ans
c'est beaucoup mieux maintenant que le
relooking s'assagir non mais cristina
cordula et le mec à 50 ans avait lâché
et se cacher les parler avec les cheveux
avec la moustache vraiment la glace et
un comptant le même esprit nous mais
nous oui mais si mais si wayne a compris
c'est incroyable cette tête de laurent
ok allez regarder un proche à regarder
un autre animateur regard des bons
d'achat mais sa série no12 chabal vous
les savanes qui règne au sein des
journaux berne on nous annonce écrit
jean pierre pernaut bien sûr il était
beau gosse pas tous en même temps cyril
valery c'était beau et je trouve très
beau se trouve très très beau
franchement oui les beaux gosses les
jeunes gars de terrain quoi comme ça
hein mais on le reconnaît bien attention
regardez très belle
ce n'est pas ma meilleure amie mais elle
est très belle marine marchande est
belle très belle à regarder moi aussi
j'aurais pas reconnue mais elle est très
belle
voilà regardez toujours toujours ben
voilà
isabelle morini-bosc regarder alors
attention la regarder il était coach
françois regardez qu'est cet animateur
regardez qu'est cet animateur avec
l'autre en soi disant le père c'est
exactement je peux le temps de dire au
revoir au public
j'ai pas eu le temps dira oui je vais
partir comme ça j'ai pas le temps de
revoir mon public on embrasse je viens
de j'adore chaque fois des voix et
excellente animateurs julien lepers
vous avez raison attention regardez
alors là celle-là elle est étonnante
grosse rigolade
regardez ça l'a annoncé qu issa et abbas
ont ce liban et ouest d'amiens aux à la
mêlée bas qu'est ce qu'il faut aussi
gérer qu'est-ce que je te prends je te
prends les aubergistes pourquoi il est
allé tout simplement faire les courses
david pujadas bénisse la coiffure mais
c'est un géant le flic à côté non non il
fait à l'ofii que le policier était
fermée 62 noms et les dates david et
beaucoup à un journaliste on y va et on
est super sexy
c'est un des meilleurs je suis pour
parler de ce mec
et c'est un mec donc c'est une
gentillesse vraiment sain abandonnait et
court beaucoup et c'est un marathon et
puis un jour
bref je m'arrête bonbons moi j'ai fait
un marathon mais facile c'est courir
après des boîtes de fait sur sa barre à
taux fixe à regarder à regarder regardez
la prochaine regarder la vie tu regardes
dans l'habitat et regarder la [ __ ]
regardez regardez
elise lucet mais elle n'a pas changé les
arrêts et lille uc sauf que là elle
vient de voir la voyez là est bien le
voir sur michel thoury latuquois oui
complément d enquête
alors là je vais enquêter non méchant
alors regardez regardez une autre
journaliste
franchement alors regardez alors on l'a
plus la vie parce qu'apparemment il dort
mal regardé prochain sophie lapix wemmel
a pas tellement changé à les mieux
armées et mieux maintenant toujours elle
a toujours été jolie elle est jolie
regardez regardez le prochain ça il va
plaire à hiva regardez sais pas si je
sais qui c'est koh lanta daigné regarder
qui sait ça s'équilibre mais c'est jean
pierre foucault c'est bien sûr c'est
denis brogniart et ouais des nîmois
d'andorre quoi vous adorez les roues à
mais oui alors déjà pu vraiment ils
n'étaient pas amis m'aurait plu ouais
bah mais vous aussi vous n'aurez pas
plus mais sans plus tarder à cet âge là
avec deux ça aurait pu se faire
on est de la même génération
soixante sept fous coin kelly la balle
est très jeune et pour finir on à
benjamin castaldi jeunes regardent c'est
bien sûr son papa jean pierre et que
vous ressemblez énormément c'est vrai on
embrasse jean-pierre c'est normal c'est
votre père c'est normal non si vous
ressembliez au clair
[Rires]